[Music]
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
speaking to the deadline after the emmy
ceremony hbo president casey blows also
confirmed that work on the show
continues
with casting royals currently undergoing
house of the dragon will begin filming
at the beginning of 2021
and will air sometime in 2022 it's based
on george r martin's book fire and blood
vol 1
and on mars yet unfinished fire and
blood vol 2 book
it's the main reason martin has not yet
finished the vince of winterbook
as he had postponed writing vince
avinter to write fire and blood
because they knew this would be a
material for a game of thrones successor
show
a certain point when we realized that
game of thrones
the tv show was winding down but there
might be successor tv shows
i said to my publishers well
we want to we've always been talking
about doing this history book which
i was calling the grimarillion
as a play on tolkien
should i finish wins first or should i
because the groomer really on is almost
complete at least up to
aegon the regency of aegon iii
and it includes material in it that is
going to be the basis of some of these
successor shows so
maybe we should get out first before the
shows
and they agreed so they said yeah they'd
finish that one
and and then go back to wins of winter
so i sat down to finish that when i
polished all of the material i'd written
i expanded a few
sidebars house of the dragon will start
a build up towards the dance of the
dragons
in the early seasons we'll cover the
dance itself later seasons however will
be based on george armand's yet
unfinished fire and blood vol 2 book
that will continue with queen rhaenyra's
son king aegon the third reign
and will include blackfyre rebellion and
go all the way to the end of the
targaryen dynasty
to robert's rebellion including the
rebellion itself
if you'd like to know a bit more of what
the show will be about well i cannot
actually spill those beans
martin teased in his blog but you might
want to pick up a copy of through
anthologists i did with garner dezois
dangerous women and rogues and then move
on to archmaester gildane's history
firing blood
dangerous swimming includes what press
materials describe as a 35
000 word novella by martin cole the
princess and the queen
or the blacks and the greens which is
about the dance of the dragons
the vast civil war that thor westeros
apart nearly two centuries before the
events of game of thrones
the greens for the faction during the
dance of the dragons that supported the
claim of aegon the second targaryen
their rivals being the blacks who
supported the claim of her neyra
targaryen
both were named for the color of their
clothes born during one tourney
rogues meanwhile includes modern story
the rogue prince or
a king's brother which chronicles their
early life adventures misdeeds
and marriages of prince daemon targaryen
considered one of the biggest rogues in
the entire history of ice and fire
finally the novel fire and blood
released in november 2018 is the first
novel of a two-part history of the
targaryens
in westeros centuries before the events
of a game of thrones house targaryen
the only family of dragonlords to
survive the doom of valyria took a
precedence on dragonstone
according to the book's description on
the author's site fire and blood begins
their tale with the legendary aegon the
conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to
hold that iconic seat all the way up to
the civil war that nearly tore their
dynasty apart
in addition to this few casting calls
have been known
i'm speaking of that of daemon targaryen
the rogue prince
confirming that the house of the dragon
will be about the dance of the dragons
the targaryen civil war miguel
sapochnick and ryan condell will serve
as showrunners and executive producers
george rr martin will also serve as
executive producer
i get many questions from fans asking if
they need to even watch the show
when they've just finished firing blood
book the answer is a huge yes
not only will there be differences
between the books and the show like it
was with game of thrones
but after reading fire and blood book
you still don't know how most of the
events really played out
some would think that you could just
read the book fire and blood to know
what will happen in the show
based on that very same book but that's
far from truth
why because firing blood is not a
non-conventional novel
its imaginary history book and according
to george armard himself not very
accurate to that
this is a book of imaginary history
chronicling the
targaryen kings of westeros it provides
a context and a background for
everything that happens in a in a song
of ice and fire and it's
uh not actually written by me it's
written by archmaester gildane
of the citadel of old town who's a a
very distinguished scholar but also a
somewhat idiosyncratic and crotchety old
man who has strong opinions on the
historical figures he's writing about so
some of his
views may creep into the text i don't
vouch for its authenticity the
targaryens were people
because wildfire in blood book was
written by george rr martin
it wasn't written from him as facts but
rather through the perspective of the
citadel's archmaester gildane
who gathered all the info and as many
different sources as he could and used
it to write the book about
the targaryen history some info is fake
some info is true some info is semi-true
no one will know for a fact what was
happening in the real history
until the house of the dragon airs in
it's it's not a conventional novel it is
imaginary history written in the style i
didn't
this is uh this book's not actually
written by me you see it's written by
archmaester gildane of the citadel
and he's writing a history and like
anyone writing history he has to go back
to primary sources
and i had a lot of fun with that because
when he gets to the dance of dragons he
has a number of primary sources but
three of them are most major he has he
has grand master or wilds official court
records
he has the septon who was
kept the the sept in king's landing and
the red keep
who of course is a is a religious figure
so he interprets everything
as to will of the gods and what was a
sin and what wasn't the same
and he has mushroom who was
semi-illiterate
and couldn't actually write anything but
who told his story
um in later years to a to a
equivalent of a monk who wrote it all
down and mushroom story of course is
always the most scandalous
girl-less um filthy version of events uh
all of which had to do with people
betraying each other and poisoning each
other and uh
having similar type fun and uh sleeping
in places they shouldn't sleep uh and
all of that
i i love the idea since this was a fake
history i didn't want to
tell it as an omniscient historian
setting down this is what actually
happened i love the idea of
telling it as a historian in world who's
trying to figure out what happened but
he's looking better as primary sources
and he's finding contradictory accounts
modern historian or someone like
archmaester gildane
has to sort through these stories
these contradictory stories and decide
which he believes and which he doesn't
believe
and i had a lot of fun being able to
tell you know
mushrooms accounts which are probably
all turned up to 37
and then the dollar accounts but i
didn't have to just stick to the dollar
account so i could give all three
and that was a great deal of fun and
gildane's sort of favorite phrase that
he comes back to is i guess we'll never
know after after presenting every
version of the story
the show unlike the book will contain
truth it will depict what actually
happened
not the change history fake or semi-true
not what might or might not have
happened
fire and blood is a complete history of
house targaryen written by georgia or
martin
from a perspective of archmaester
gildane who wrote it many decades after
the events took place
sure most of the main events such as
battles and deaths probably did happen
but as gildan says it in the books the
full truth about what happened behind
closed doors
in the privacy of stairwells council
rooms and bad
chambers he does not fully know and he
turns to many different sources
which usually differ from one another he
looks into the course of chronicles
laid down by grand maester runciter and
his successors
and many court documents as well gildane
looks into accounts written decades
later by the children and grandchildren
of those caught up in the events of
these times
while they are undoubtedly of use so
much time has passed between the event
and the recording that many confusions
and contradictions have inevitably crept
in
unfortunately this is also true for
gildane's two accounts by first
hand observers that have come down to
him
septemestus who served in the royals
stepped in the red cube during much of
his time and spent much time as a
confidant and confessed her to king
viserys and his queens
his account is biased favoring aegon ii
over rhaenyra
the second account is based upon the
verbal account of the court full
mushroom
who was present at court for all of them
for king viserys princess and queen
rhaenyra
and both king aegons the second and the
third
during his reign king baylor the first
targaryen had mushroom's book burned
on account of its scandalous content
there are several main sources for
historical information on the dance of
the dragons
which are frequently at odds with each
other gildan also uses source written by
grand maester orwell
who had served king gage in the second
targaryen on his council and was
arrested by the forces of queen rhaenyra
targaryen
when she took the city or while wrote
his account while locked away in the
black cells
uncertain about whether he would survive
the war he attempted to paint himself in
the best light possible
grand maester monkens the dance of the
dragons that true telling was based on
orwell's account
using all these sources which often
differ from one another
archmaester gildan wrote his work firing
blood his work about the history of
house targaryen
this format brings up martin's major
thematic point about the uncertainty of
memory
and history being written by winners
neither side truly won the war
and the decades after the war both sides
wrote their own biased history books
trying to put their actions in a better
light
histories written by the greens they
picked again the second in good light
and rhaenyra in a bad light on the other
hand histories written by the blacks do
the opposite we'll know exactly what
happened in this time period when the
show comes out
and that's why you cannot just read fire
and blood book and think you would know
what actually happened or what will
happen on the show
books are written by archmaester decades
and decades after the events happened
using many sources that in most cases
are very different from each other
and most of them are biased as well the
dance of the dragons was the most
devastating war in the history of the
seven kingdoms
the war of succession between aegon ii
and his sister rhaenyra
over their father viserys the first
throne both of them thought they
belonged on the iron throne
when people started declaring for one of
them or the other their fight divided
the kingdoms in two
targaryens fought targaryens brothers
fought brothers
dragons fought the dragons by the time
it was over thousands were dead
the conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only
house targaryen
but large parts of westeros as well
additionally devastated the targaryen's
dragon population
ultimately leading to their extinction
within a few decades
they never truly recovered by the end of
the reign of king viserys first
targaryen 20 dragons were alive
the majority of these died during the
civil war called the dance of the
dragons
which began in 129 ac and lasted until
mid 131 ac
the show will not jump straight into the
fight it will start with a few episodes
of the prelude to the targaryen civil
war
with king viserys the first likely dying
after a few episodes
which is just enough to introduce as
they told the characters
and which side they support as the
future heir as well as to set up all the
animosity at the court
king viserys the first targaryen had
three children by his first
queen emma aaron but only one princess
rhaenyra survived to adulthood
lacking a son to succeed and viserys
began to train rhaenyra to be his heir
named her his heir and rhaenyra soon
acquired support of hundreds of lords
and landed knights
the king remarried in 106 ac this time
to alice sent hightower
and had four more children aegon helena
eamon and daron
in 111 ac a great journey was held at
king's landing
on the 5th anniversary of zaryus's
marriage to alison
during the opening feast queen allison
wore a green gown
while princess rhaenyra dressed in the
red and black of house targaryen
note was taken and soon all of
rhaenyra's supporters started wearing
black clothing
while all of alison's followers started
wearing green
over the years the popular names applied
to both factions were inspired by the
colors they more
rhaenyra supporters were called the
blacks and dagon the second followers
were called the greens
vista is the first strengthened
rhaenyra's place in the succession
by marrying her in 114 ac to sir lane or
valerian
who himself had targaryen blood through
his mother princess rhinis
rhaenyra gave birth to three sons
jacarius lucero sent joffrey valerian
during her marriage
although there were rumors that the
father of this princess was not lanar
but sir harvin strong after laner was
killed in spite's town in 120 ac
rhaenyra married her uncle
infamous rogue prince prince daemon
targaryen
the younger brother who is there is the
first her sons by him were aegon the
younger
called so to distinguish him from his
uncle alice and sagan who was
occasionally called aegon the elder
and viserys the relationship between
rhaenyra and alicent declined early in
alison's marriage to viserys
since both ladies had been trying to be
the realm's first lady
and there could only be one alison's
father sir otto
hightower had also disliked rynera's
second husband
prince damon since the beginning of his
aerys reign
the war began when king viserys the
first died
his designated heir for many years had
been his only surviving child by his
first
wife his daughter rhaenyra since viserys
the first later remarried however
and had several younger children by his
second wife alice and hightower
the eldest of which was rhaenyra's
half-brother aegon ii
the seven kingdoms had never had their
ruling queen before
and many were troubled by the thought of
rhaenyra succeeding to the throne
by the inheritance law of the andals a
younger brother
succeeds ahead of an elder daughter but
the targaryens had never formalized
royal inheritance laws for their new
realm after the war of conquest 130
years before
viserys the first however had extracted
the oaths of filthy from the major lords
of the realm
that rhaenyra would succeed him the same
day that viserys the first died aegon
the second followers the greens staged
the coup
and he was soon crowned in king's
landing rhaenyra as the princess of
dragonstone had her power based on
dragonstone island
where she responded by being crowned the
queen and declaring aegon a traitor
aegon the second's main supporters were
his mother alison's family
the powerful house hightower that rules
oldtown
as well as the lannisters rhaenyra's
main supporters were her first husband's
family
house valerian as well as her mother's
house aaron and her uncle and future
husband the most dangerous man in the
seven kingdoms
and the most experienced commander
daemon targaryen
the blacks were mostly in the
northeastern half of westeros
while the greens were mostly in the
southwestern half dorne was not yet part
of the realm
and remained neutral during the war the
blacks included the aryans the starks
and the tullys
along with most if not all of the
riverlords even the phrase
the starks felt bound by honor to remain
true to the filthy oats
they had made to rhaenyra and her father
was still alive
major greens included the high towers
and lannisters
reiner had thought the baratheons would
give her support
but in what she saw as a major betrayal
they decided they taken the second
the greens faced their own betrayal
however they had assumed that all of the
reach would side with the greens
but instead the northern half of the
reach sided with the blacks
even some of the high towers own direct
vessels in the south sided with the
blacks
the tyrells remained officially neutral
throughout the war
the greens had thought that the greyjoys
would join them not realizing that the
great wealth they controlled ironically
made them a more enticing target
seeing a small profit and sailing all
the way to the eastern side of westeros
to raid the modest lands of the vale or
dragonstone
the graduates nominally sided with the
blacks in order to raid the lannister
hightower lands along the eastern coast
despite the greens controlling the
wealthier lands of westeros
the blacks had the advantage of control
of the seas the greens only had the red
vine fleet to rely on for naval power
while through house valerian rhaenyra's
forces controlled most of the royal
fleet
after the greyjoy sided with the blacks
however the iron fleet tied up the red
wines in their raids on the west coast
giving the blacks free run of the
eastern coast the greens attempted to
counter this by allying with the kingdom
of the three daughters
an alliance of liz smir and tyrosh whose
fleet assaulted rhaenyra's fleets in the
massive battle of the gullet
one third of the valyrian fleet was lost
but the two-thirds of the
three-daughter's fleet was destroyed and
the survivors fit the drew from the rest
of the war
over all this meant that despite the
green's numerical superiority
they had to slowly struggle to march
their armies over land
to attack the blacks instead of being
able to quickly move their larger armies
by sea
after rhaenyra was crowned queen by
daemon at dragonstone and declared her
her
brother a traitor king gagan ii declared
rhaenyra and daemon traitors as well
after being persuaded by his mother
alicent and sister helena
aegon dispatched the grand maester or
wild to dragonstone
with a retinue under a peace banner
offering rhaenyra generous terms
but was refused rhaenyra's sons departed
on their dragons to seek allies
and make pacts on their mother's behalf
her eldest son jacary spent visiting the
aryans of the eerie
the men released of white harbor and the
starks of winterfell
rhaenyra's second son luceris traveled
to baratheons at storm's end
prince damon led the blacks attack on
harrenhal which was conquered without
bloodshed
the castellan sir simon strong yielded
when he saw demon's drag on characters
this conquest led to victories of the
blacks at the burning mill
and stone hedge and allowed the river
lords to gather at harrenhal
in the meantime jacarius gained lady
irene and the lords manderly
borland sunderland and craig and stark
to rhaenyra's cause
with lord starkey lying through the pact
of ice and fire lustrius flew to storm's
end
arriving before a gathering storm he
found prince daemon and his dragon vogar
already present eamon tried to get
lucerus into a fight
insulting him calling him a strong
bastard but lucerus who sworn to his
mother
not to fight refused him he delivered
his message to lord boris baratheon
but was refused and told to leave boris
prevented aemond from attacking his
cousin in the castle
but did allow for the prince to follow
him mounted on his dragon eamonn caught
up with loose race during a raging storm
the fight between the two dragons did
not last long vagar being five times
bigger had the advantage
and rx felt broken his head and neck
washed a short three days later
along with the corpse of luceries ryner
collapsed when learning of lucery's
death
prince damon at harry hall sent a raven
to his wife
promising that her son's death would be
avenged using one of his friends from
king's landing daemon
enlisted the help of a former sergeant
in the city watch
known known as blood and the red catcher
from the red keep
now known only as cheese the two sneaked
into the red keep
using secret tunnels and hidden doors
which brought them into the tower of the
hand
their queen alicent was bound and gagged
and her bad maid strangled
when queen helena and her three children
appeared blood and cheese bar the doors
and told helena to choose which of her
sons would die
helena reluctantly chose mailer but
blood did the opposite
and killed prince jaehaerys instead the
two fled with the prince's head
the war was a stalemate with many
unexpected victories as well as
unexpected losses for both sides
with no clear victory emerging even
king's landing itself was attacked
though there was no siege rhaenyra's new
husband damon her own uncle
had reorganized and essentially created
the city watch
as it would later be known and they
remained loyal to him
after the greens foolishly left the
capital city lightly defended to attack
rhaenyra's armies gathering at harrenhal
her forces on dragonstone moved against
king's landing
and the gold cloaks threw the gates open
at their arrival
the war eventually degenerated into a
near anarchy
as the string of betrayals happened in
rapid succession on both sides
rival kings started popping up in
different parts of the realm
ranging from the greyjoys behaving
functionally independent
the dragon riders deciding that they
would make better kings than rhaenyra or
aegon the second
to even petition thugs carving out their
own fiefdoms thinking's landing
and declaring themselves king of have
the city there's many interesting and
legendary side characters as well
we have a combination of varys and
littlefinger in larry strong
being the one in shadows orchestrating
many events and making kings rise and
fall
we also have melisandre is alice rivers
eamonn targaryen's mistress and perhaps
that's even melisandre herself in her
younger days
alice sees visions in the flames and has
some great powers
rocalia rindon pirate king is another
legendary side character in the story
if you even have the stories about him
are true he's probably one of the most
insane
and most fascinating characters i've
ever read it's a targaryen civil war so
of course targaryens and their dragons
play the main roles in series
but the stark's laney surfs air
installis and hightowers are very
important as well
one of the most exciting 1v1 fights is
definitely legendary daemon targaryen
against aim and one eye that happened
above the god's eye
and resulted with both men and both
their dragons dying
although daemon did win a fight by
piercing his valyrian steel sword
through aemon's eye socket
but seconds later both dragons hit the
lake at rapid speed
eamon's body was found but demons wasn't
historians say daemon died in this fight
but singers sing of his departure from
westeros to live out his days in essos
i'm not going to talk about every single
event but all of these things i
mentioned is what essentially
kick-started this dance of the dragons
referring to viserys's death animosity
between the greens and the blacks
especially the first fight where
rhaenyra lost her son
did turn into a violent long bloody tale
full of revenge
violence lost love and dragon to dragon
aerial battles
the civil war lasted two years and
gutted the seven kingdoms
with dragons burning out vast swaths of
the countryside
and the entire towns reduced to ashes
the devastation
was so great that it took a full
generation to recover
at the start of the war there were 20
living dragons
9 older and huge dragons 8 younger
dragons
still large enough to be ridden to war
and 3 hatchlings too small to ride
by the end of the war all but three had
died
another dragon was hatched near the end
of the war bringing the total number of
surviving dragons to four
none of them would live for long and
there were too few dragons left to
maintain a stable breeding population
the last dragon said to be a stunted
creature died only 33 years after the
war ended
later in the reign of rhaenyra's son
king aegon iii
for which he became known as aegon the
dragonbane
20 major battles even more smaller
battles
and even more betrayals turn cloaks and
twists
all of that this game of thrones prequel
show house of the dragon brings in 2022
thank you so much for watching hope you
enjoyed this video and let me know what
team are you on in the comment section
down below
team black supporting rhaenyra or team
greens supporting aegon